[Music]
let me start by asking was it as much
fun to make as it appears to have been
to to be there i mean it was it was so
much fun to make because of this cast
and crew you know um
like
to make a film with margaret chow you
know it's kind of like the den mother is
um so special and um
the cast uh
they're they're so funny and uh
they they all understood the
um
the importance of a movie like this and
so
i think the shared the common goal like
was very um
uh galvanizing um but yeah units like we
spent
um two weeks on the island together um
and we stayed in
uh like a bed and breakfast and not not
one of these houses not one of those
houses but uh but a kind of
you know house uh
that um like my room shared an air vent
with joel kimbuster's room and um
i could hear him watching real
housewives of beverly hills
with the rest of the cast and they would
like giggle and it just like i was like
oh i was like oh this is the bennett
house you know it's so cute um
and
uh margaret was giving um
uh our actor who plays keegan tomas
matos um
like a bustier
and like you know fashion and clothes
just because margaret was like you
should wear this stuff and so it's just
really fun to um
to be around that kind of energy it was
hard it was like the weather was really
difficult we had two hurricanes you know
um
this was shooting last summer this was
last august september
and you know we had a big hurricane uh
while we were on the island that um
the water level rose in the bay and so
uh
we were going to shoot one of those
sunset scenes
and the water was above the dock
you know and we just looked at it being
like what do we do you know and so we
had to pivot really quickly and find
other time in the schedule and hope that
we got a pretty sunset you know so
um it's like i lost like 10 pounds out
of like anxiety you know
because of things that we couldn't
control but um
you know i i
i don't think i could have gone through
with those difficulties if it weren't
for the fact that it was like such a fun
you know group of people to be around
so the scope of this i mean so you've
made two films prior to this both of
which are really
intimate and you know focused on small
groups like families and
uh here you have just a massive cast
compared to that
you know and in a party environment and
um
i mean you've already been talking about
this a little bit but how is that at
adapting to that for you as a director
managing the scale of that
that size cast in production yeah you
know i mean i i know what my strengths
are as a director and and
um i'm always going to
um protect the heart of a movie um
i think it would have been really easy
for a film like fire island to like kind
of dip into like
superficial fluff you know and i i
saw in joel's script a real
um you know emotional core and i wanted
to
emphasize that um
and so
that felt familiar but it was a really
different
you know
uh sense of scope you know with
um
the the locations the set pieces
you know and and the ensemble cast it
was such a big cast
you know and i wanted to give each of
them so much of my time and energy and
you know
you just have to
understand as a director
like okay
like in this scene
like like who who's the the person i
need to focus on you know and and
in this coverage who i need to focus on
and and just be able to
um prioritize and then
like spread the wealth of my attention
as much as possible but the cast was
also so distracted and like in love with
each other that like i didn't have to
hold their hands too much
um
but uh
you know i i think um it was a real uh
you know a
learning lesson for me to just um
be able to
to
you know herd cats that
way so
as with any great jane austen you have
like there's the primary relationships
and the primary romance that you're
following throughout the story but then
there's also the social world and the
different social the strata
and we i think you
balance those beautifully in the film
and again it's such a departure from
your previous work where you're
like man it's not just about the scope
but it's about you you really do track
the emotional through line of the key
relationships and then pull back and as
a viewer i felt totally like i knew
where i was i knew what was going on and
i was fascinated and drawn in by all of
it in terms of the broader social
dynamic of what's going on
um i mean like
thank god for jane austen you know we
had a really good blueprint um
and uh
and and joel and i
um you know really trusted in
the
the structure of
of
you know her narrative um
you know we also like had great
adaptations to watch you know the bbc
adaptation is joel's favorite
um the joe wright film is my favorite
um
uh the joe wright version is my favorite
and um you know uh
i think
there's just a real elegance to
um you know the plot of pride and
prejudice and
uh you know we we had to make
adjustments obviously to fit it to
um
uh
to fit it to
you know gay culture fire island but it
was um
a really
in a weird way uh the
the parallels were really obvious you
know like i love that like the big
netherfield ball is the weekly underwear
party you know like that makes so much
sense you know and like once you know
that that's
the netherfield ball like then you know
that like
darcy and lizzy should have a moment on
the dance floor together you know and so
like it just started to click into place
in a very fun
way um could you talk about how this
project came to you was this a script
that you sought out like you knew about
and went after or did they come to you
how did this become an andrew on film
yeah i mean i'll be like very honest
because i think it's like a fun story um
that i don't tell super often but it's
it's out there in the public um
uh
fire island was initially at quibby it
was a quibby show um and
um
and and i interviewed for it and i
didn't get it it went to a different
director
and my joke is that um
jeffrey katzenberg didn't think i was
funny enough um but i
uh he's laughing now
but uh i know i i like that we also
gotta prod quibby a little bit on the
movie but um
yeah we um
we
uh i i didn't have any hard feelings you
know like i was like if that's
if that's the director they want great
totally fine um and then could be
shuttered and then a year into the
pandemic i got um an email saying hey
like fire island is set up at
searchlight
as a feature would you be interested um
and
i read it and i think you know in a
weird way i think i was better
positioned or
you know even more excited to make it as
a feature at that point you know
a year into the pandemic i hadn't seen
my friends in a long time i hadn't like
gone out to a club and
you know like gone dancing and drinking
and you know being stupid and so
um i saw in the script so much of what
was missing in my life
in that moment and so i was like i
really want to do this you know even
more than before
um and i pitched my little heart out to
you know searchlight and was really
lucky that they
uh saw my vision for it um and
you know got to make the movie that's
fantastic yeah so when you came on was
joel kinbooster was in the obviously he
wrote it but was also in the in the lead
role yeah any of the other cast in place
or how talk about casting it yeah so
bone was already in place joel had
written it for him and bowen
um and and that's part of what i love
too about the um
uh
you know about the project was that joel
and bone are real life friends and i
love being able to
to um show a friendship on screen that's
authentic like it's such a um
uh
such a privilege and a treat um you
don't have to work to make people like
each other you know um
but uh we had to figure out the rest of
the casting and
you know uh
we had the the group the main group and
um
uh margaret cho
like it was kind of a no-brainer
interestingly in the script um that
character was gender swapped from pride
and prejudice to be a an older gay man
um but then margaret reached out to the
production and said hey i love you know
joel and bowen i'm really interested in
you know being a part of this and joel
and i looked at each other and were like
oh like
this makes so much sense like she is mrs
bennett you know and um
and so we we cast her um matt rogers is
really good friends with bowen and um
joel
and i just thought uh
he reminds me so much of
a gay jenna malone
and jenna malone plays um lydia in the
um joe wright adaptation and i was like
yeah like you're the one that's gonna
get into trouble you know like um
and uh and i just think he's
so funny um
and then um taurian miller who plays max
uh joel uh had cast him in a play in
chicago and
um
he is just so funny so natural
and then tomas matos is like a total
discovery this was their first feature
film
they went to that you know famous new
york high school the fame high school
laguardia
and
they just have this natural
charisma
that we really loved and we got them all
together and i was like oh this is this
is right you know so we were really
fortunate the hardest casting was mr
darcy you know that was the trickiest
one
joel
uh told me he was like i need to be
attracted to them and that's already
kind of annoying
you know um but um he's fantastic conrad
is amazing their scenes together are
just really really beautiful i love that
conrad just kind of has like a different
speed from the rest of the cast you know
you kind of it's a bit of a record
scratch and i i love that about
the um you know the character um but i
remember we
did a bunch of chemistry reads with joel
and
really great actors too and uh
each time joel felt like he had the
upper hand in the power dynamic um and
conrad was the only actor who flustered
joel and um like during the chem test uh
joel went up on his lines he forgot his
lines and he wrote the script you know
um
and i i immediately was like oh this is
this is right like this is really good
you know um
and for me it was just extra gratifying
that like
that conrad is asian american you know
um
i was just so excited that we have a gay
asian mr darcy like that feels so
special yeah absolutely
did you bring anyone onto the film who
you'd worked with previously on your
crew any of your leads or um
um i had tried so hard uh
you know i um
uh it it was a real learning experience
for me because it was my first union
production and a lot of my previous crew
aren't union and so you know that was a
an obstacle
it was also in new york um
and i don't know as much crew out there
some of my crew is busy you know and so
uh you know we really had to meet a
bunch of people you know i think we
ultimately ended up with the the right
people it's a little bit like
you know things work out for a reason
you know like
quibby
like
me coming on board when it's a feature
like i i really believe in that um and
so
uh you know we had a really um
like lovely
uh crew that um
you know that i i know i'll work with
again in the future that's great
um let me open it up to the room here
i'm sure other people have questions
as well
yeah back there um what was the process
of choosing the music
it was so good yeah um you know we
worked with um
our music supervisors at 20th century um
so patrick houlihan and uh natalie
anderson and um
you know it was uh really funny because
uh
like you know they're they're not gay so
like we just have to try and like do a
big kind of gay fire island education
you know um
and
i love that like patrick would say like
like do alipa he kept calling her like
um dua lipa and i thought that was
really like cute for a straight man you
know
um
but um uh you know they they really
found like uh like beautiful music that
um you know made the island feel really
rich um our editor brian cates who i
think is
the best in the biz he um edited short
bus and um tamara jenkins films so the
savages and private life
i loved him and he
you know he made a couple of choices in
here the two perfume genius songs were
his idea and i loved them um
and
pure imagination the willy wonka you
know cover at the beginning like that
was brian's idea
um
you know uh i worked with joel for
certain songs uh so noah uh will dancing
to kim petra's heart to break that was a
joel idea
um
you know so it was kind of a group
effort um
but uh you know
we knew that it was super important and
i i i think
initially searchlight
didn't totally realize how much music
there was going to be in this movie um
and then when they saw the cue sheet
they're like oh like yeah this makes
sense but now we're like a million
dollars over budget and music
so we had to do some really smart
post-production shuffling
speaking of music could you talk about
the scene where bowen sings yeah that
was an amazing scene yeah was that it
was that as scripted or was that
something he brought and what just
wanted to do i believe
it was scripted
as um
uh will you still love me tomorrow is
that like the ronettes or something um
but
uh
you know kind of a throwback like an
oldie and
um joel and i talked about it and we
said you know ultimately like we should
we should ask bowen like what he would
want to sing and um
bowen um
sent over a list of music and
uh
you know it was a lot of carpenters and
um
and then some like robin
but then uh and it was britney spears
sometimes and i was listening to the
lyrics um you know thinking about it for
the movie and it just made so much sense
it's very jane bennett you know like
um
uh
i i just really thought it was super
special and it's always really fun for
me like i've seen this movie with
audiences a couple of times and it's
always fun for me for people to start to
realize that it's britney spears you
know
um
but yeah and then we wanted to bring it
back again for that big you know kind of
rom-com moment and we were trying to
find a cool queer
you know um uh artists to uh cover the
song and um joel really loves that band
muna um and they did such a beautiful
cover and we're so happy with it you
know um that we wanted to to really
feature it so um you know it was it it's
it's one of my favorite moments in the
movie yeah that's the britney spears
karaoke and and then the coming back
later in the film
uh other questions
don't be shy
yeah i've never been to fire island so
thank you that seemed amazing i can't
wait to go have you been i mean did you
have that experience i feel like you
gave away a lot of the secrets
especially with some of the uh
darker scenes and i'm so
glad that you showed that side of life i
mean
what has your experience been like yeah
you know we didn't want to shy away from
the fact that like fire island isn't
like
a perfect place you know like it still
exists in this world it still exists in
this country and so there is going to be
racism and classism you know um it's not
uh immune to those things um and i
didn't want to sugarcoat it and and joel
didn't either um so it was really
uh
we
we wanted to
show that part of the island i had
actually i'd never been to fire island
before and i like was very uh honest
about that when i interviewed for it um
but i had friends who had gone and i
knew a little bit about the history of
the island um one of my favorite poets
frank o'hara like famously died on the
island um
uh he got run over by a car on the beach
um which is why they like don't have
cars on the island anymore um but um
uh
i
when i got the job i was like i'm going
to go as much as i can i've been to
other gay havens like palm springs and
provincetown so i had a sense of what
this trip symbolized but i didn't know
the trappings of it like you know joel
did and so i just asked joel a ton of
questions i
went as much as i could during
pre-production um my cinematographer
felipe var durray and i uh we went to
an underwear party together which is
really funny and we were like shot
listing in our underwear and
then we ran we ran into joel kim booster
there
like out in the wild like he was just
there having fun
which was really great to see because um
i could see how
much fun he was having and i could see
the joy that he was trying to capture in
the movie
you know just kind of unfolding in front
of me as we were hanging out that night
um
and so
you know it i definitely still have a
bit of an outsider's perspective but i
think that
um
[Music]
uh
that made me more objective in a way you
know and uh and i think the characters
have a little bit of an outsider's
perspective you know um
in the film and so uh i didn't
uh i didn't feel like
i couldn't tell the story i just had to
you know
do the right preparation make the right
you know kind of collaborative choices
and and you know really utilize joel to
help me fill in my like fire island um
you know knowledge gaps
i wanted to ask
another question about working with joel
so he
wrote the script starred in it and was
also a producer on it i'm curious were
there
when you came on board
did you suggest any changes to the
script did it evolve a bit when you came
on as director
and sort of what was that relationship
like working with him you know where
he's wearing those different hats
throughout the shoot yeah uh you know it
was interesting like joel has written a
lot of television but this is his first
like feature screenplay um and
uh and actually
the screenplay was
uh stitched together quippy episodes you
know and um
there was some smoothing over that had
to happen
um kind of in that process of making it
into a feature um you know i my
my big thing was i
wanted to um
uh
kind of strengthen the romances a little
bit more
um you know the film is so much about
chosen family and about the friendship
um which is what i love about it um uh
but uh you know i wanted to to feel a
little bit more of that um
uh you know like sexiness that romance
um
you know the uh
the beach date scene you know that's set
to that perfume genius song that doesn't
have any dialogue like i wanted to
expand that you know so there are a lot
of directorial things that affected the
script in in some ways um
uh and then there are just uh production
challenges um so uh
uh
you know like casting conrad um
uh
he was never um
specified as asian-american in the
script
um
but having him be asian american
actually changed some of the the
dialogue and the way that these two
characters would interact um
and so uh that was that was something
that joel and i had to to work on um
and then uh
the the big rom-com moment um where
charlie professes his love to howie um
initially actually was supposed to take
place
um kind of from
the harbor
uh like as the fairy was pulling out um
and charlie would run and talk to howie
on the ferry and then
um charlie would jump into the water and
then howie would jump into the water and
they would kiss in the water um and we
were so excited to shoot it and i like i
had told my stunt guy like i was like i
want to make sure we have a stunt double
that jumps into the water like a gay boy
because that's so important um and
um
and then we tested the water per sag um
and it came back as like toxic basically
um
it had 10 times the amount of e coli you
know that's safe
um and
uh and
and then they told me
that the test only tests up to 10 times
more
and like bone was going to go to the
emmys the next week and i just was like
i don't want to kill bonyang
i don't want him to like
diarrhea at the emmys you know
so we we had to find a new ending um and
so that was a you know a real kind of
group effort you know joel had a vision
for it but he was also acting and we
were already shooting at that point you
know so it's
you know it really takes a village but
um you know i think we found something
that didn't involve the actors getting
into e coli infested waters
that's good
very wise
it's kind of i didn't know that this had
was initially intended for quibby it
doesn't and i don't feel the episodic
nature of it at all it feels very
cohesive yeah and i mean
the thing i love about is how you
embrace the rom-com elements and also
subvert them at the same time throughout
i mean that's what's so fun about the
film yeah i mean i i love that um
you know that the central relationship
of the movie is actually a platonic
friendship like that to me feels so
um queer and modern you know um
i think uh there's something about queer
people like we really value
you know our our friend group in a way
that um you know like i think
is in some ways more significant than
like our romantic relationships and so
um that felt really
uh
important um
and
and i think just you know
joel and i both really love rom-coms but
you know we also wanted to use the genre
as a bit of a um
like a trojan horse to talk about
like elements of the queer community
that um
you know like need work you know uh and
so that um
it just felt uh so
uh smart and i i
as a director i didn't want that to get
smoothed over if anything i wanted to
emphasize those things
um
so that uh it felt substantial you know
i think a lot about
um
you know i think comedy is only funny if
you um
have
uh you acknowledge the pain that it
comes out of you know and so like that
was was really important for me
um to to ground this and make it
actually
like feel joyful like i wanted you to
like
like feel excited by the end of the film
mm-hmm
other questions
yeah
yeah so it looked like it was just
yeah you know um i i really wanted them
to like have as much fun as possible and
working with amazing comedians you know
um
uh
i
definitely uh
you know created an environment where
they could do that but it's it's
interesting like working with comedians
um
uh you know for many of the cast it was
their first
you know movie or their first bigger
movie where they had a leading role and
um
uh i remember uh the first week of the
shoot uh
a couple of them would
come up to me after a setup and they'd
be like was that okay like was it funny
and i was like it was great and i
realized it was because they didn't hear
laughter you know and so
um i started throwing takes you know
like like the first take of each setup i
would just laugh really loud so that
they felt like it was working you know
um and then they would relax into it a
bit um and the sound the sound people
were like what are you doing and i was
like it's a plan i know don't worry um
but um but yeah like so many of the the
best moments in this film these like
throwaway lines like were just like
them having fun and
um
you know uh like me giving them the room
to do that and um you know finding
moments to
um
uh
you know uh brainstorm ideas like that
joke about i was an early investor in
quibby like that wasn't scripted that
was that was a brain trust in the moment
you know where i i said like oh like
like how did she lose her money like we
should talk about it you know and and
and joel and margaret and bowen and matt
were like thinking about it and i i
think it was joel that was like oh like
let's take a pot shot at quippy you know
so so uh you know i i
as a director who's mostly done dramas
and i really wanted to do a good job
with this comedy like i scanned the
script and was like is there a joke
opportunity here and on set i would
bring it up and you know like see what
you know that the cast would do
i love the line about what is it lindsey
graham and oh lindsey graham and the
parent trapped in their parents right
yeah like that that was that was in the
moment that was totally in the moment
yeah i'd see that yeah it's so good it's
so good yeah um and so that you know
it's really fun to be able to
um
uh
like
guide the cast into something and like
utilize their talent for you know like
awesome moments
um well
andrew i want to end with a
a really corny question
when you
introduced the film you mentioned your
association with film independent and
you did a screenwriting lab the
directing lab project involved
and i'm just curious like thinking back
on where you were when you were first in
project involved
like what advice what what what would
you say to that person
today coming off this film and with your
experience now
with spa night with driveways and now
this like looking back where where you
were at at that time and what your
expectations were i mean i'd be
what would the wise andrew aaron have to
say
i'd be a little bit afraid that if i
like told my younger self something that
i would somehow like butterfly effect of
another path and like
it would be like back to the future
where like my film career slowly spades
from it wouldn't go up
because yeah i might screw myself up but
um
you know uh i remember like in project
involve um
uh
uh francisco and jane had brought in a
guest uh and it was james shamis and he
spoke to our group and
um
and he said like you know i i think it's
very cool that i'm here talking to you
all but like
like there's nothing i can really say
that's gonna
like change anything like you you just
need to go out there like you need to
make stuff you know and i was sitting
there being like oh
and so i left like i left early it was
like
you know i was like
i don't know what james is going to tell
me like he's already telling me that
like there's nothing you can say
um and so i went home and i like started
working on you know a script um
and and there is something about like
it's like you want to be a filmmaker
like you you ultimately have to make
things you know and it doesn't matter if
they're super small
you know like i remember going to
sundance with you know my second short
film and
you know someone asked uh you know that
really annoying question like what was
your budget and we went down the line of
each filmmaker in that shorts program
and
you know i had spent like eight thousand
dollars in credit card debt you know to
make my short and then other filmmakers
said that they spent 120 000
and i was like we're in the same place
you know and i spent like multiple times
less than you
um and so i think it's you know it's
like
like use the resources that you have and
tell a great story
um
and and you know like enjoy the enjoy
the process um
you know
at the end of the day i think
what makes that possible is is having a
community you know like filmmaking is
not a solo endeavor and i think a lot of
people like
whether it's the ego of being a director
or
just being scared to ask for help like
you know you really do think about it
like like this is on me but um
if you have a group of friends if you
uh meet um collaborators like that makes
it so much
more fun and also just more achievable
um and so
it's like i'm so thankful for
um you know these organizations like
film independent that have um
uh
you know put me in touch with people
like given me a network you know my
first tv job
i got um
because the executive on that show
um was a
a fellow project involved
um
uh
uh fellow um
uh in my class you know and she had
remembered me
um you know and and that was my first
you know like paid paid gig
um and so i i i really love being able
to
um
yeah just like foster a sense of
community like do events like this where
you can all like get to
like share a communal experience um and
get to know each other
absolutely andrew thank you so much
congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
you